autre rassemblement contre le pass
sanitaire celui du mouvement union
citoyenne pour la liberté ou encore
celui du patriote partie du pont des
invalides écoutez justement au micro de
sébastien dufour leur chef de file
florian philippot ce dernier qui réagit
à la décision du ministère de la santé
ce matin de ne plus reconnaître les
autotests antico vide à partir de
vendredi prochain
il démontre là et se démasque ces
politiques ça n'est pas sanitaires même
chose quand ils disent les doses les
autotests ne seront plus valables après
le 15 octobre il démontre que c'est donc
politique et non plus à lutter c'est que
c'est pas assez cher même les doubles
vacciner en fait sont pas à l'abri parce
que dès janvier prochain et vous
expliqueront qui va il faut faire une
recharge est ce que votre double vaccin
il sera plus valable vous avez dit
militer baisse s'est très vite donc fort
à faire une troisième injection israël
en est à la quatrième
donc on va être personne n'est à l'abri
d'un couac ceux qui cautionnent ça ou
restent silencieux parce qu'ils sont
eux-mêmes vaccinés ou double vacciner ce
qui n'est pas le cas de tout ça il ya
des double accès qui sont contre ça déjà
mais ils n'osent pas cautionner ça parce
que tu as ça va retomber aussi sur le
corps du museau à un moment ou un autre
c'est quoi le but en fait c'est qu'elle
est là cette folie alors qu'on voit bien
que dans les pays qui sont moins
vacciner ou qu'ils ont pas fait de
confinement par ailleurs et ça on a en
fait la même épidémie c'est vraiment la
même chose partout ce qui ce qui est
quand même premièrement ça doit
interroger